ready for this yes I am
do a keel
you will be building up the largest
weapon we have ever asked Miss to make
in Fortune fire history
white Smith's the next four days you
will be building this
the nine foot long fry Outlet spice
my name is David Warner I'm 37 years old
I'm from Kirkwood Missouri
I have twins boy and a girl and I would
say that amazing twins has prepared me
really well for this competition because
I can deal with stressful situations the
prowler spice dates back to 16th century
Northern Italy the massive pole arm
features a 37 inch long Central Blade
with two curved side blades the shaft
could measure up to six feet long
perfect for delivering lethal thrusts
and slashes upon enemy Cavalry over time
this enormous weapon took on a more
ceremonial roll and at its longest
spanned more than 10 feet today the
brother spice can be seen on display at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art in New
York City
the Groot Pierre sword
my name is Michael Dillon 54 years old
been forging for 30 years I started
making knives for props in the movie
industry I'm pretty confident but
wearing my pants may fall down that's
why I have a belt and suspenders during
the 16th century a larger than life
warrior in the Netherlands known to the
locals as Group Pierre or the giant
Pierre wielded this massive sword in
battle pure size made him the subject of
folklore and Legend but the physical
size of his sword speaks for itself the
15 pound nearly seven foot tall sword is
the largest European sword ever to be
used in combat as a mercenarian pirate
Group Pierre is believed to have wielded
this weapon with ease delivering
devastating blows to any enemy that got
in his way and it can be seen today at
the freeze Museum in the Netherlands
kind of nervous about making something
that's this size and then to put a spear
socket at the end of it that's also a
challenge and then get to attach to the
socket you know it's going to be a
pacing challenge I need to start shaping
the handle I've made some Spears before
but nothing quite like this
so I need to make sure that the handle
will actually fit inside the socket I've
got to make sure that there's a pretty
precise fit so I think what I'm going to
do is heat up
this guy and trying to use that heat to
press this in the post by surround there
to get a nice seal on that shaft
that's what I was going for and
yesterday I got the blades quenched I
just need to assemble everything and
sharpen it
I think this blade has got a pretty good
shot of bringing home 10 000 bucks
it was hungry
I'm used to building Big Stuff some of
my sculptures weigh up to 6 500 pounds
so this is in the realm of what I'm used
to working on
my quench tanks buried six feet in the
Earth
here we go up this ladder
this thing is huge Garden formal done
the plan is to grind a pound and a half
off this blade
everything's coming out nice shape
and I'm going to start the finish of the
blade and the guard and the pommel
I'm really happy with it
I really gotta hit something with this I
just can't let it pass
nasty
placements welcome to the dynamic kill
test
but as massive as your weapons are it's
not as massive as my disappointment that
I can't wheel them today because of my
injury here but I Leave You incapable
hands with the man of the plan who'll be
my hand Dave Baker
David you're up first you ready for this
yes I am all right let's do this
thank you
so David when you swing at a nine foot
weapon it's pretty wild it went into the
pig with no resistance whatsoever the
blade it's all still true it's all still
sharp nicely done Doug you got anything
bad
your weapon you'll kill
all right Michael your turn you ready
sir yes sir let's do this
all right Michael that's a beast that's
a beautiful Beast now your Edge is sharp
that really Cuts deep into the pig
carcass it is a nice heavy weight but
controllable and more importantly
do a keel thank you sir
bladesmiths welcome to the dynamic
strength test
to test the strength and overall
construction of your weapons I will be
pushing on these poles snapping all 10
of them and then piercing these steel
drums
Dave you're first you ready yes I am all
right
thank you
all right David well your blade held up
great in piercing the drums took some
serious flex but came right back to true
the side blades here they penetrated
that barrel and I don't even see any
indication that they were in there all
in all I think he did a great job and uh
your weapon held upgrade
thank you Michael you ready for this
give it hell oh good because this is so
much fun
foreign
it's a little bit more of a firm blade
it doesn't quite wiggle as much as far
as damage just the very edge has rolled
but I would not drag my finger down that
edge it would still open me up I knocked
out of the park well done thank you
forged in fire war of weapons
[Music]